good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we are just
hours away from the national election
and suddenly there is so much going on
so much news it is impossible to
metabolize
claims and slogans and rumors coming in
from
every direction been online recently
checked your phone
it's overwhelming we're going to have
the very latest news
throughout the hour tonight we want to
begin a different way we want to begin
this show with a single image now the
image doesn't
tell you who's going to win or lose
tomorrow
instead it's a metaphor for the election
itself and for the moment that we're
living it and will continue to live in
the picture is from a town called butler
pennsylvania it's 35 miles north of
pittsburgh the president held a rally
there over the weekend
butler's like a lot of places you'll
find in this country once you head
inland from the coasts
it's a former industrial town they made
pullman rail cars there for many years
but it's been losing population for
decades there's still a lot of nice
people in butler for 60 grand you can
buy a decent house there
it's a place you might be happy in but
our professional class is not impressed
by butler
they don't consider butler pennsylvania
or places like it
the future to them places like butler
are embarrassing relics of a past
best forgotten the men of butler may
have built this country and they did
but they mean nothing to our leaders now
you can be certain of that because when
large numbers of people in butler
started killing themselves with
narcotics
no one in washington or new york or los
angeles said a word about it
and so it continued there have now been
so many opioid deaths
in butler that a few years ago residents
built an overdose memorial in the middle
of town
msnbc didn't cover that so given all of
that
it was interesting how the people around
butler feel about donald trump
here are the pictures of the president's
rally there on saturday night
tens of thousands of people came so many
people
that the crowd obscured the horizon it
looked like a visit from the pope
when was the last time a political
speech drew that many people
well the media didn't ask instead they
attacked the rally as a super spreader
event
trump endangers thousands in
pennsylvania
okay we'll leave the epidemiology to cnn
but the question still hung in the air
why did all those people come
why they must have known that donald
trump is the most
evil man who's ever lived they've heard
that every day for
five years they know that people who
support donald trump
are also evil they're bigots they're
morons they're racist cult members
they know that americans have been fired
from their jobs for supporting donald
trump
not to mention kicked off social media
belittled by their kids teachers
shunned by decent society only losers
and freaks support donald trump
people in butler knew all of that but on
saturday they went to the donald trump
rally anyway
why exactly did they do that we should
be pondering that question
deeply as we watch tomorrow's returns
and as we live through the aftermath of
them
millions of americans sincerely love
donald trump they love him in spite of
everything they've heard they love him
often in spite of himself
they're not deluded they know exactly
who trump is they love him
anyway they love donald trump
because no one else loves them the
country
they built the country their ancestors
fought for over hundreds of
years has left them to die in their
unfashionable little towns
mocked and despised by the sneering
halfwits with finance degrees but no
actual skills
who seem to run everything all of a
sudden whatever donald trump's faults
he is better than the rest of the people
in charge at least he doesn't hate them
for their weakness
donald trump in other words is and has
always
been a living indictment of the people
who run this country
that was true four years ago when trump
came out of nowhere to win the
presidency
and it's every bit as true right now
maybe even more true than it's ever been
and it will remain true regardless of
whether donald trump
wins reelection trump rose
because they failed it's as simple as
that
if the people in charge had done a
halfway decent job with the country they
inherited
if they cared about anything other than
themselves even for just a moment
donald trump would still be hosting
celebrity apprentice but they didn't
instead they were incompetent and
narcissistic and cruel
and relentlessly dishonest they wrecked
what they didn't build
they lied about it they hurt anyone who
told the truth about what they were
doing
that's true we watched
america is still a great country the
best in the world but our ruling class
is disgusting a vote for trump is a vote
against
them that's what's going on in that
picture that's what's going on in this
country